Thomas Jane actually stabbed a guy in the chest,
and Joe Pesci gave Macauley Culkin a
permanent scar…with his teeth.
Thinkacting is all fake? These actors have
the hospital bills to prove it isn't.
It's tough to be James Bond. Sure, you
get the cool cars, the high-tech gadgets,
and the slick tuxedos, but you also have to
contend with any number of villainous henchmen,
assassins, and thugs prepared to
batter you senseless at every turn.
Stunt work on Bond films has always been
intense, but the franchise's fight scenes
have grown particularly brutal in their
execution during Daniel Craig's tenure,
and he's got the wounds to
prove it. During the filming
of "Spectre," Craig went toe-to-toe with
professional wrestler-turned-actor Dave
Bautista during a fight scene that was
supposed to take place on a moving train.
At one point, Bautista threw Craig across the
train car, and while the move was planned,
the way Craig landed was not. Craig tore
a meniscus in his knee and had to take two
weeks off from filming for arthroscopic surgery.
He doesn't blame Bautista, though, and in fact,
he accidentally got his revenge by breaking
Bautista's nose when they later reshot the scene.
"I threw this punch. I hit him on
the nose and I heard this crack,
and I went 'Oh God no' and ran away."
Professional wrestling legend Jerry "The King"
Lawler once famously feuded with the iconic
and infamously confrontational comedian
Andy Kaufman. Sixteen years after that,
Lawler was called upon to recreate the feud
by playing himself in the Kaufman biopic "Man
on the Moon." This time, Lawler would be
acting opposite star Jim Carrey, who was
only supposed to be pretending to be Kaufman.
Carrey took his role very seriously, though,
and things got real for Lawler once again — even
more real than they had ever been with Kaufman.
As covered in the documentary "Jim & Andy: The
Great Beyond," Carrey was relentlessly devoted to
playing Kaufman, remaining in character during
the entire production of "Man on the Moon" to
the point that he puzzled and often frustrated
his collaborators. Things sometimes got heated,
and that included scenes with Lawler.
At one point during the production,
Carrey — in character as Kaufman — spit at the
wrestler, prompting Lawler to get physical. The
exact nature of the injury isn't clear, but it
was enough to briefly land Carrey in a hospital.
Even years later, Lawler was still expressing
his unease at how far Carrey took everything.
"Well, Jim Carrey's an idiot."
Though the "Rocky" films are often very
melodramatic and bombastic in their portrayal
of the title character's story, creator Sylvester
Stallone still always wanted to aim for some level
of realism during the making of the series. In
"Rocky IV," in which his character faces Russian
boxer Ivan Drago on a quest to avenge the death of
his friend Apollo Creed, Stallone drew inspiration
from a real-life boxing match featuring two
fighters who hated each other outside of the ring.
Reasoning that Rocky and Drago would also hate
each other, Stallone instructed actor Dolph
Lundgren to actually hit him during
the opening moments of their fight.
"I must break you."
As requested, Lundgren came out swinging…and
he hit Stallone so hard in the chest that he
had to cut the scene short. Stallone knew the
punches were serious, but he didn't know how
serious until later that night when his blood
pressure shot up and he had to be flown from
Canada back to the United States for emergency
medical treatment. Stallone later explained:
"He hit my heart so hard that it banged
against my ribs and started to swell,
and that usually happens in car accidents."
Actors understand that injuries can happen
during intense sequences, particularly when
the make-believe of a scene involves a physical
struggle. Sometimes, though, the real drama of
a moment lives on long after it's committed to
film. This was the case with "Gothika," the 2003
thriller that earned a lot of coverage in the
entertainment press thanks to an on-set injury.
During a scene in which her character,
Dr. Miranda Grey, is being interrogated,
star Halle Berry was supposed to struggle
against co-star Robert Downey Jr.,
who was supposed to attempt to restrain her.
Berry approached the scene with such intensity
that Downey accidentally broke a bone in her
forearm while trying to hold her back. The
injury made headlines, and Downey was frequently
asked — to the point of frustration — to explain
what happened while he tried to promote the
film. In one of those interviews, he told IGN:
"I would say to her, 'Listen. You're badass,
but you weigh 102 pounds and your bones are
as thin as, like, Crayolas. [...] Then
I turn out to be the a—hole who's like
trying to put her arm down with my
hand open and I feel her ulna snap."
Channing Tatum received some of the best reviews
of his career for director Bennett Miller's
2014 drama "Foxcatcher," which was based on true
events that happened at John du Pont's self-funded
wrestling training facility in the 1990s. As
Olympic wrestler Mark Schultz, Tatum worked hard
to reach a certain level of realism and intensity
in each scene, and it sometimes cost him. In one
memorable moment, Tatum slammed his head so hard
through a prop mirror that he hit the wall behind
it, leaving him with a cut. In another, Tatum's
demand for intensity led to yet another injury —
this time at the hands of co-star Mark Ruffalo,
who played Mark's brother and coach Dave Schultz.
For a scene in which Dave slaps Mark upside
the head, Tatum asked Ruffalo to hit him for
real. Ruffalo did, but Tatum immediately
regretted his request. Tatum told Variety:
"He pops my eardrum. All of a sudden it's just
making a screeching noise. I can't hear anything."
Tatum's eardrum ultimately healed,
but the look of pain on his face
in the finished film after Ruffalo
slapped him was definitely not acting.
AMC's massive zombie hit "The
Walking Dead" is an intense
show full of shocking death scenes
and undead battles. And, of course,
brawls between its often at-odds human
characters. As the show's leading man,
Andrew Lincoln was often at the forefront of these
confrontations, and he took his job seriously.
According to co-star Norman Reedus, in an
attempt to keep his energy high, Lincoln
would often get very caffeinated before the show's
most intense scenes. This, plus Lincoln's tendency
toward clumsiness, would sometimes lead to his
co-stars unceremoniously getting punched in
the face. Reedus described one such encounter
on "The Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon."
"He's supposed to run and tackle me
off-camera, right? Just jump into an
airbag. But he jumps and he punches
me in the face with double fists."
And that was apparently far from the only
accidental injury Lincoln caused. Reedus
noted that Lincoln had developed quite the
reputation for his accidental punches. It
was such an issue that Jeffrey Dean Morgan,
who plays Negan on the show, called Reedus up
one night to express his dread over shooting a
fight scene with Lincoln the following day. The
result? About what you'd expect, according to a
photo Morgan texted Reedus following the scene.
"It's Jeff with a bandaid on his
nose, with an ice pack, right?"
"No."
"Yeah he punched him in the
nose, like fractured his nose."
Anyone who's ever seen "Goodfellas" knows that
Oscar-winner Joe Pesci is an actor with a talent
for playing very scary characters. And it's
a skill that Pesci himself apparently takes
quite seriously, even when he's using it for a
light family comedy. In the holiday classic "Home
Alone," Pesci plays Harry, the smarter and more
savage of the two bandits who attempt to terrorize
and rob Macaulay Culkin's Kevin McCallister, only
to find that he's more than they bargained for.
"You guys give up, or you thirsty for more?"
Though he's ultimately playing an
overconfident buffoon, Pesci still felt
he needed to make Culkin uncomfortable
during their scenes together. In fact,
he deliberately kept his distance from the young
star on set until it was time to actually play
the scary bad guy. But even Pesci didn't mean
to go quite as far as he did in one scene.
During their final confrontation after the bandits
catch Kevin and prepare to pay him back for all
the pain he's caused them, Harry threatens to
bite off all of the boy's fingers. In the film,
he never actually gets to, as Kevin is
saved at the last moment. In real life,
Pesci accidentally bit Culkin during
one take and left a permanent scar.
"It broke the skin and everything. I'm
a little nine-year-old boy and he's
going around biting them. I still have the scar."
Most of the time when an actor injures one of
their co-stars, it's an accident. Other times,
it's the product of said co-star demanding
to be struck for the sake of realism. Then
there are those rare moments, like one
that happened on the set of "The Texas
Chain Saw Massacre," when someone just
really wants to get the scene over with.
The famous "dinner" scene in Leatherface's
house in "The Texas Chain Saw Massacre" was
filmed in one marathon shooting day in an
un-air-conditioned house in the relentless
summer heat. The actors were covered in sweat,
the stench in the room was overpowering,
and everyone involved was beginning to go a little
crazy as they were pushed to their working limits.
This craziness ultimately manifested itself as
a real injury during the moment in which Gunnar
Hansen's Leatherface cuts Sally's finger
to feed her blood to Grandpa. The blade
of the knife was covered with tape to make
it dull, and Hansen was supposed to pretend
to cut actress Marilyn Burns, then squeeze a
bulb full of fake blood concealed in his hand
to make it look like Burns was bleeding.
According to a 2003 DVD commentary track,
when the tube that was supposed to squirt
out the blood kept clogging, Hansen got so
frustrated that he pulled the tape off and cut
Burns for real, just to get the scene over with.
In 1995, the "Mortal Kombat" film roundhouse
kicked its way into theaters and into the
hearts of moviegoers around the globe. While
expectations were low — especially since the
video game movie curse was still in full effect —
fans were blown away by the fierce and thrilling
action on display. Part of the reason the
film worked is because director Paul W. S.
Anderson employed actual fighting experts in
pivotal parts. For the role of the spectral,
fire-breathing ninja Scorpion, Anderson hired
martial artist and stuntman Chris Casamassa.
One of the best fight scenes
of the film takes place between
Linden Ashby's Johnny Cage
and Casamassa's Scorpion.
"Get over here."
The two begin their battle in a forest before
being transported to another eerie dimension,
concluding the bout in fiery fashion.
It's a brutal exchange of fists and kicks,
and one of Casamassa's attacks actually
left Ashby in considerable pain.
Speaking to The Hollywood Reporter,
Ashby explained how Casamassa helped
him prepare for the fight scenes, but he
said there was an unintentional accident.
"Chris did an ax kick to my kidneys in
that fight. I had a pad on but his heel
just came right between the pads and got me in the
kidney, hard. I was peeing blood. It hurt a lot."
Not quite a fatality, but definitely painful.
As the star of 2010's "The Expendables,"
Sylvester Stallone got to test his mettle
alongside other action heroes like Dolph
Lundgren, Jet Li, and Jason Statham. However,
it wasn't any of them who caused
damage to Sly this time around.
"Only an idiot would do this job."
"How much?"
"Like I said."
During the movie, Stallone's Barney Ross squares
off against "Stone Cold" Steve Austin's aptly
named character, Paine. Austin, of course,
is well known for his mudhole-stomping and
Stone Cold Stunners in the WWE. It appears
as if the Texas Rattlesnake brought the same
energy to his performance here, but it left
Stallone a little worse for wear in the end.
Speaking to FHM Magazine, Stallone revealed
the intensity of the fight scenes in the film,
including one that left him
needing surgery afterward.
"Actually, my fight with Stone Cold
Steve Austin was so vicious that I ended
up getting a hairline fracture in my neck.
I'm not joking. I haven't told anyone this,
but I had to have a very serious operation
afterwards. I now have a metal plate in my neck."
In 2020, Halle Berry marked her directorial
debut with the Netflix sports drama "Bruised."
Berry also stars in the film as MMA fighter
Jackie "Pretty Bull" Justice. Expectedly,
she gets the opportunity to show
what she is made of in a few scenes.
In "Bruised," Justice's main opponent is Lucia
"Lady Killer" Chavez — portrayed by real-life
UFC fighter Valentina Shevchenko. Speaking
to Sports Illustrated, Berry revealed that
Shevchenko played a major part in ensuring
she was prepared for the film by training
her. The actor also said that they decided to
film their big fight early in the production,
which was when Berry quickly found out just
how painful MMA can really be. Berry said:
"On Day 2, I got kicked and broke two ribs. And,
you know, there was a moment when I thought:
'We can shut this down and I can go heal, or I
can keep going and just fight my way through it.'"
However, the actor decided against
it, considering all the time that
both she and Shevchenko had invested in the
training, as well as how a delay could result
in the entire film being canceled. So she
pushed through the pain to film the fight,
saying she waited until they had the scene
before telling anyone about her injury.
For Ryan Coogler's "Creed," a decision was
made to take the realism to the next level
by casting real boxers in the film. Michael
B. Jordan's Adonis Creed steps into the ring
against "Pretty" Ricky Conlan, who is
portrayed by real-life champion boxer
Tony Bellew. Much like Sylvester Stallone
took a proper hook from Dolph Lundgren
in "Rocky IV," Jordan tasted a knuckle
sandwich in the movie, courtesy of Bellew.
Appearing on "The Graham Norton Show,"
Jordan revealed that there was a need to
get footage of him taking a punch for
a slow-motion sequence. There is no
way to fake that type of scene so he had to
take a real punch from his co-star — twice.
"And, action."
While Jordan said he didn't quite get
knocked out, he did feel the impact, adding:
"It felt like I was in a car accident
for like four days afterward. Tony said
he only went 40 percent; it
felt like 85. It was tough."
Compared to other films mentioned here,
Francis Ford Coppola's "The Godfather"
isn't exactly bursting with intense
action that should result in broken
bones and busted lips. Sure, there's
violence on display, but there should
be no reason for the actors to suffer any
on-set injuries apart from a freak accident.
However, the memorable scene where Sonny
Corleone lays into his brother-in-law,
Carlo, carries a bit more bite because of
the real-life bad blood between the actors.
Apparently James Caan and Gianni Russo
had developed some hostility toward each
other throughout the production of the 1972
film. They still rehearsed their big scene,
but when it came down to the day
of the shoot, Caan started to do
things differently and more viciously.
Russo explained to Entertainment Weekly:
"He improvised a few things like that
little billy club he threw at me when
I came off the stoop. He hit me right in
the head with that, and then he throws me
over the railing and he's biting my hands.
[...] None of that was supposed to happen."
"And when I crawl out, he literally
lifted me up with his kick."
Russo added that the beating left him with
injuries including broken
ribs and a chipped elbow.
The story of 1989's "Cyborg" merits a book.
While it might appear like one of The Cannon
Group's trademark low-budget action films, there's
a lot of history behind how this production came
to be. The short of it is that Cannon planned to
shoot "Spider-Man" and "Masters of the Universe
2" at the same time to cut costs, but plans fell
apart. Since Cannon had already spent the money on
costumes and props, filmmaker Albert Pyun wrote
a script over a weekend that became "Cyborg."
Jean-Claude Van Damme signed up to play the
lead role of Gibson Rickenbacker, and it was
off to the races. As with any film featuring
Van Damme, "Cyborg" is all about the action,
and there are countless fight scenes in the movie.
In one of the sequences, Van Damme's character
battles a gang of pirates, one of whom is played
by former bodybuilder Jackson "Rock" Pinckney.
Unfortunately, an accident occurred when
a prop knife went into Pickney's eye.
According to the Orlando Sentinel, Pickney
sued and was awarded $487,500 in damages.
Rob Reiner's "The Princess Bride" is a beloved
1987 fantasy film that has stood the test of time.
"What can I do for you?"
"You can die slowly, cut into a thousand pieces."
It's a riveting action-adventure story that
follows Westley as he tries to rescue the
love of his life, Princess Buttercup. It
boasts plenty of exciting action sequences,
but the scene that knocked actor Cary
Elwes out cold came during a relatively
tame moment. It happened during
a scene in which Count Rugen puts
Westley down for the count by bonking
his head with the handle of his sword.
According to Elwes' book "As You Wish:
Inconceivable Tales from the Making of
The Princess Bride," Christopher Guest, who
played Rugen, had no intention of harming
him with his metal sword in the scene. The
problem was it didn't look great on camera. So,
Elwes said, he encouraged Guest to "slightly
tap" his head and he would move. Elwes wrote:
"Chris swung the heavy sword down toward
my head. However, as fate would have it,
it landed just a touch harder than
either of us anticipated. And that,
folks, was the last thing I
remember from that day's shoot."
"I woke up in the hospital with stitches
being sewn into my forehead, and the scene
that you see in the movie is in
fact me being knocked out for real."
On a more lighthearted note, the most famous
injury in The Princess Bride didn't come from
any physical altercation whatsoever. It
happened during the scene in which Inigo
and Fezzik take Westley to be healed by
Miracle Max, played by Billy Crystal.
Crystal improvised much of his material
as Max, churning out jokes on the set for
three days while his co-stars fought to hold in
their laughter during filming. In many cases,
they were unsuccessful, breaking character
during takes because Crystal was just too funny.
Mandy Patinkin in particular, though,
really wanted to make it through the
scenes without laughing, and it cost
him. By the time filming was done,
the effort actually gave him a physical injury.
"The only injury I sustained on
that movie was I bruised a rib
from holding in my laughter with Billy
Crystal, and that's God's honest truth."
If Sean Bean is in a movie, chances are his
character won't make it to the final credits.
No matter if he's a good or bad guy, Bean's
on-screen personas seem to be fated to dance
with the grim reaper under the pale moonlight.
In 1992's "Patriot Games," Bean's character
Sean Miller doesn't make it out alive either —
unsurprisingly. Though, in this case, he is the
villain, so no one can be too upset about Harrison
Ford's Jack Ryan putting him in a watery grave.
Miller and Ryan have an exhilarating final
encounter on a moving speedboat. Throughout
the clash, Ryan looks to be on the back
foot and overpowered by Miller; however,
the CIA's favorite child perseveres and
puts his opponent down once and for all.
As Bean revealed on The Compleat Sean Bean,
the scuffle between him and Ford resulted
in him receiving the infamous scar on
his face. While shooting the scene,
Ford accidentally hit him with a boat hook,
which cut just under Bean's left eyebrow.
"The Punisher" is finally getting its
flowers years after its 2004 release.
Starring Thomas Jane as Frank Castle, it is a
bloody good time that doesn't shirk away from
violent encounters and manages to capture
the tone of the comic book character. It
might not have the body count of Marvel's
next big-screen stab at the character,
2008's "Punisher: War Zone," but it did
feature its own literal on-set stabbing.
Appearing on "The Rich Eisen Show," Jane revealed
that someone had forgotten to replace the real
knife with the prop. So during the scene where
Castle fights the hulking Russian — played by
ex-pro wrestler Kevin Nash — Jane stabs
Nash in the chest with an actual knife.
"It stabs him, and it goes in, and I'm
looking at the knife, I'm looking at him,
Kevin, and he's just looking down at me, and
there's a knife sticking out of his chest."
The actor said he expected Nash
to lash out and react in anger,
but Nash didn't. Nonetheless, Jane
said he still felt terrible about it.
For his part, Nash has said that he doesn't
hold any grudges about what happened,
but he says that the people
in charge of props should be
doing their jobs more diligently to avoid
these types of incidents from occurring.
"He just sat there and looked at the knife,
looked at me. Shook his head. I
sent him a couple cases of beer."
"Bloodsport" is widely seen as the film
that catapulted Jean-Claude Van Damme
into superstardom, and it's also recognized
as one of the greatest martial arts movies
of all time. While most fans remember
"Bloodsport" for the vicious final fight,
there is another swift battle that stands
out — albeit for a different reason.
An earlier fight scene with actor Bernard
Mariano ends with him making one last
attempt to get Van Damme, who puts him
back down with a chop to the face. The
scene looks great on film; however,
it wasn't the best time for Mariano.
Speaking to South China Morning
Post, Mariano explained:
"When we rolled the first take, he moved too
fast. [...] He was already moving back and caught
me full on the jaw and split my lip. I passed
out and was taken to hospital and stitched up."
Mariano insisted that the blood on the mat, which
appears in the final cut, was actually his own.